là ces deux bandes noires lever la main
ceux qui pensent que cette bande est
plus petite que celle là malgré les
apparences ces deux traits noirs font
bel et bien la même taille reconnaître
et comprendre une illusion d'optique
un exercice pas toujours évident surtout
lorsqu'il s'agit de l'expliquer d'ecs et
rick compose de voir les en fait non
quelque chose que tu vois où tu sens où
tu entends mais qui n'est pas vrai
illusion d'optique contrairement à ce
qu'on pense pas une illusion créée par
l'oeil c'est une illusion qu'on voit
mais qui crée par le cerveau justement
le cerveau se tromper créer une logique
là où il n'y en a pas c'est là que
naissent justement les illusions
d'optique
parmi la dizaine d'enfants participants
à cet atelier certains découvraient pour
la première fois ce phénomène et rien de
mieux qu'une petite mise en pratique
pour s'en rendre compte qu'on termine
l'atelier par la fabrication d'une
chambre dame qui est donc une illusion
je pas si vous connaissez c'est vraiment
on fait rentrer deux personnes dans une
salle qu'en mai à les deux personnages
bouillant même qui par est démesurément
bond par rapport à l'autre parce qu'en
fait la forme de la salle n'est pas
vraiment celle d'une salle mais notre
oeil la perçoit comme tel et donc se
consacrer quelque chose dans le cadre de
la fête de la science de nombreux
ateliers sont proposés jusqu'au 21
octobre une exposition manip sur la
lumière est actuellement à découvrir à
la médiathèque de la verrière